pourquoi avez vous choisi de devenir
aide soignant les autres ça me plaît
beaucoup
vous pouvez me parler de vos précédents
patients les derniers en date tribord
sous raymond premiers patients d'après
les statistiques très bas encore sept à
10 ans d'espérance de vie
alors on n'a pas droit à l'erreur tout
est clair t'en a pas marre de rester
cloîtrés sortir que pour aller au parc
une fois par semaine je suis sûr qu'au
moins une partie du toit rêve de voir le
monde
ouais c'est clair mais si je commence à
faire des voeux je mettrai ça après
celui d'enfiler les pom pom girls des
seahawks pendant qu'elles font la
pyramide humaine
c'est une carte des plus minables
attraction visibles sur les routes de
cette grande nation le trou le plus
profond du monde c'est ultra déprimant
j'adore je savais que ça te fallait bien
de prendre la route fait j'en mangeais
un slim jim non or c'est le goût de
l'amérique et les squats chez toi
croquer donc très cher danseurs slim jim
d'après toi qu'est ce qu'elle fait là
elle est folle de mon corps c'est
évident c'est quoi ton problème
une dystrophie musculaire de duchenne
merde ça fout les moulins je m'appelle
dot prévoir ya une place pour moi dans
votre équipe
ben mon fauteuil est coincé ben et moi
boston
donc ton rêve c'est de voir un méga trou
dans le sol une grande ambition dans la
vie
on sent vers un des messages mais bien
sûr si on aurait dit james bond 4.5 mon
pote d'asie je peux pas faire ça chiale
et ne met pas en avant
bon eh oui c'est lamentable
tu as des raisons
mais les chiens
ben
tu